should you move the rocks on your island
to create your very own rock garden and
animal crossing new horizons
today we'll talk about five things you
need to consider before
moving rocks on your island people of
the internet retrorecontour here if
we're meeting for the first time i'm
just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell
we post videos every week here on
youtube and today we're back with
another animal crossing new horizons
video
so by now there are plenty of guides
online showing you the best way to move
rocks in animal crossing but take it
from someone who's already created a
rock garden my own
there are some things you should
consider before you go about doing this
number one it will take time
how much time well it depends it depends
largely on how good you are
counting squares in animal crossing
seriously and also how well you know the
overall layout of your island
you see the most commonly recommended
way of moving rocks and new horizons is
to use
mannequins again there are plenty of
videos out there that go into great
detail showing you how to do this
but in short you'll have to position
these mannequins across your island on
every fourth tile where you don't
already have another item the basic idea
is that you destroy the rocks on your
island
and then set up items in every single
space
where you don't want the rocks to go and
then all you're left with is a couple of
open spaces where you want the rocks to
go
and this will take a while it's also not
the most
exciting of tasks so your best bet is to
do it in phases
or if you want to knock it all out in
one session then you might want to do
something like throwing on a podcast or
maybe an audio book and listening
as you go about the project in fact if
you happen to be looking for a new audio
book right now you can get a free trial
of audible plus and
two free audiobooks using my affiliate
link in the video description below
as for moving rocks by positioning
mannequins this is the method i use and
it's probably the most efficient because
once you have the rocks in place
it's very easy to quickly remove the
mannequins you simply need to make a
single pixel change to the mannequin
design
and they'll all disappear setting the
mannequins up though isn't nearly as
simple as getting rid of them
if you do happen to do it perfectly the
first time then it will take you roughly
a week to move
all of your rocks if you don't mind time
traveling you can use that to speed up
the process but even then
it's highly unlikely you'll get enough
mannequins placed and spaced out
correctly
the first time i know it took me a few
days before the rocks started spawning
in the proper location because of a few
tiny areas on my island that i had
missed when originally placing the
mannequins
number two make sure you find a place
you'll be
happy with if you go down this path then
you'll most likely want to stick with it
for the long term
if you were to position your rocks in a
place you weren't satisfied with or you
change your mind later
then you'd have to start all over and
we're back to square one again with it
taking up
a ton of time i feel like most people
out there really enjoy designing the
layout of their island and considering
this is one of the more time consuming
activities out there
you'll definitely want to get it right
the first time i would recommend using
the various paths in the game and maybe
some fencing to visually map out your
planned layout
before you start destroying rocks and
placing mannequins
you may even want to try out a few
different combinations before you
ultimately decide if you're happy with
the spot you've chosen
just know as long as you aren't
destroying rocks they'll remain in their
exact position
all the time through all the different
seasons which leads us to
number three you can't choose the style
of the rock
you may have noticed as you've played
animal crossing there are a few
different
rock appearances but for those who are
very particular about their island
layout
you should know there's no way to
determine which style of rock you get
and how it will be oriented in my own
rock garden you'll notice how
five of the six look very similar and
then the final one here in the top right
has a very different appearance
from the others i suppose if you don't
mind waiting even more days you could
keep all your mannequins up and destroy
a rock that you already have in place
hoping you would get another one but
again there's just no way of knowing
which style of rock you'll get
also no matter how long you wait and no
matter how long you go without
destroying rocks
six is the maximum number for your
island in new horizons
on that front though if you start
feeling a little destructive and just
want to blow off some steam you can
always use a nook miles ticket and head
to an island where you can freely
destroy
every rock in sight number four rock
farming gets
much easier this here is a very nice
side effect of having all your rocks in
one place
it makes farming them and looking for
the various rock materials much
easier and more time efficient of course
in new horizons your island can have up
to
six rocks and they're all destructible
each day five of the six will produce
crafting materials like stone
clay iron nuggets and when you're lucky
gold nuggets the remaining rock will be
your lucky money rock of the day which
rewards you with bells when you strike
it
so from the moment you have all your
rocks in their final position
mining them each day gets much easier
that being said
the fifth thing you'll definitely want
to consider is that now you have to be
extremely careful when eating fruit
trust me on this one guys you do not
want to accidentally destroy
one of your rocks after you take all
this time and effort to get them
positioned in your exact
desired location remember anytime you
eat fruit
always make sure to keep an eye on the
counter and be absolutely sure it's
completely drained before you go
anywhere near one of your rocks if you
happen to destroy one of the rocks
after you've moved them and after you've
removed all your mannequins
then unfortunately you're back to square
one again
and would need to reposition the
mannequins
the best thing to do here is to develop
a habit of always
checking to see if you've eaten any
fruit before you go and mine your rocks
each day
hopefully now you have a much better
idea of whether or not building a rock
garden is worth it for you
if you're new to the game i've prepared
a full beginners playlist which you can
find here on the right side of your
screen
and if you're in the mood for a laid
back evening let's play of animal
crossing then check out my video on the
left side of your screen
as always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon